عندما يفرط مرضى الصداع نصفي وصداع التوتر
في استخدام ادويتهم يمكن ان يسببوا
لانفسهم المزيد من الصداع هذه الحاله تسمى
صداع الافراط في استخدام الادويه ولم
يتوصل الباحثون للاسباب الدقيقه الا انهم
يعتقدون انها تؤثر على عمل الدوبامين في
الجسم وهو ناقل عصبي يعاني مليارات
الاشخاص في العالم اما من الصداع نصفي او
الصداع الناتج عن التوتر والحل الاسهل
بالنسبه لهم هو استخدام الادويه التي لا
تستلزم وصفه طبيه واذا زاد استخدامها اكثر
من يومين او ثلاثه ايام في الاسبوع فقد
يصل المريض لمرحله الافراط في تناول
الادويه هذا الاضطراب يؤثر على ما يقدر
بنحو 100 مليون بالغ على مستوى العالم في
النهايه فان افضل طريقه لتجنب الصداع
الناتج عن الافراط في تناول الادويه هي
تقليل فرص الاصابه بالصداع في المقام
الاول
[موسيقى]